hi guys I'm Eric Voss and ever since
Game of Thrones went on hiatus last
summer a lot of you guys have been
asking for an update now a few months
back we asked you guys on Twitter on
Facebook on our patreon page to send us
all of the big questions that you have
about season seven then not too long
after that the show's production kicked
into gear for season seven and Belfast's
in Spain resulting in a ton of leaked
set photos and production schedules and
actor sightings resulting in rumors
spreading now I've actually covered some
of this stuff in a preliminary season
seven predictions video that I made
right after season six ended last summer
and you can tell it was summer based on
that sexy open shirt hope you brought
your sunglasses but in this video I'm
gonna build on those predictions by
answering some of your questions with my
own theories some of which may be total
[ __ ] okay so first question
Raul tweeted us asking about the in-game
/ Aria what's her purpose where is her
story going how does it connect to the
greater story okay let's talk about Aria
before I predicted that in season seven
Aria would basically take on the Lady
Stoneheart storyline so without spoiling
it Lady Stoneheart is a badass character
from the books who leads the Brotherhood
without banners on a bloody rampage
throughout the Riverlands killing
Lannister's and phrasal to get revenge
for the red wedding and since the show
seemed to piss on that possible
storyline my thought was that Arya would
carry this torch of vengeance working
her way down her list after Walder Frey
going after the Hound in Melisandre and
eventually Cersei and since my overall
theory was that season 7 would conclude
the wars between men setting up season 8
to be a final existential war between
man and White Walkers my prediction was
that Arya whose storyline has nothing to
do whatsoever with the White Walkers
currently would die maybe in like a
suicide mission like taking out the Mad
Queen Cersei
maybe after killing Jaime and wearing
his face mask as a disguise but let's be
honest it's probably not gonna go down
like that right because Arya had her
chance to kill Jaime at the twins and it
seems like she made her decision to
spare his life then and even though
we're looking at the next 7 of the final
13 episodes of this series and a ton of
big characters are probably gonna start
dying off george RR martin has said that
arya is his favorite character and she
may be one of the last few standing at
the end of the show so I have a few
alternate theories about Arya
Aria told lady crane that she wanted to
see what's west of Westeros and in our
breakdown of that episode we talked
about how Aria named her direwolf Maria
after the ancient warrior Queen Maria
who traveled west from Essos and
conquered and colonized Dorne and by
going west of Westeros REO might be
following in numerius footsteps
colonizing some new world west across
the sea but a few episodes later arya
told Jackie Naggar that she planned on
going home a girl is a stock of
Winterfell and I'm going home in bike
home I assume she means Winterfell and I
just don't think the show would have her
say this without having her return to
Winterfell at some point so to answer
your question Vishnu on Facebook will
Arya join Starks again or continue to be
an assassin until she has done with her
list I think it could be both like I
think there's a good chance that we'll
see REO rejoined the Starks and
Winterfell with her sister Sansa and her
half-brother John I mean her Targaryen
cousin John his family sure he's very
confusing but I think arias still has
some assasinate to do like it's a long
walk up the Kings Road from the twins
which means plenty of ways we could see
Arya get her hands pretty bloody like
after Walder Frey and his sons there are
still plenty of phrase left I could also
see her running into Brienne remember we
last saw Brienne in that same Riverlands
area rowing upstream from Riverrun and
real quick c'mon she on Facebook ass
will we see in the mariya again and what
will it mean could she return with more
wolves and I definitely think that we
will see the mariya in season 7 now I'll
say that the show has kind of downplayed
the dire wolves important like in the
books it's implied that the stark
children are all wargs not just bran and
they share a magical and spiritual
connection with their dire wolves but
the show hasn't really gotten into that
so Arya hasn't seen Demaryius since she
forced her to run away in season 1 but
considering that the show went to the
trouble to tie in the loose thread of
the missing Benjen stark last season I
would be super surprised if they didn't
bring back to mariya for at least one
little reunion moment with Arya okay
moving on we had a lot of questions
obviously about Jon Snow Michael tweeted
how do you think John and Danny will
meet and team up and caval tweeted
asking for a theory on how far Jon Snow
family lineage will be shown and how it
may turn how stark against him so let's
talk about Johnny
snow or is it john-san now because he
was technically born in the south or is
it John Targaryen or like Jo Harris or
Aegon Targaryen depending on how
accurately we read Lana's lips I'll get
to that so in the last video I predicted
that Jon would join forces with Daenerys
and this aunt and nephew would marry to
unite all of Westeros against the White
Walkers with the two of them becoming
the titular Song of Ice and Fire that
the book series is called and of course
none of us would feel weird because this
show has made incest super sexy and okay
but now I'm not so sure a full marriage
will even be necessary because Daenerys
told Tyrion last season that she didn't
really care about love and marriage and
I don't think jon is interested in
having any connection to the Iron Throne
still I do think these two will meet
next season and there's a few ways it
could go down one way is war like
Daenerys is army and dragons could
invade Westeros from the south and make
their way up north and John as the
goo-goo-goo north will be forced to
defend everything above the neck
resulting in these two meeting on the
battlefield but I just don't see that
happening I think that the show revealed
John's Targaryen lineage now in order to
bring him and Dany together on the same
side so while I could see these two sort
of monarchs squabbling over who kneels
to whom and who's naked resurrection was
more legit I think ultimately they're
both wise enough to see that they need
each other and who knows we could get
some action between these two that
doesn't require anyone to print out
screenshots of their naked bodies and
rub them against each other who would
who would do that there's some real
freaks online now as to the question of
John's lineage I predicted before that
if word gets out that John is the
Targaryen that would threaten his rule
in the north and I know there's some
debate over this since John still has
stark blood through Lyanna but it does
matter the lordship of Winterfell passes
down through the direct children of Ned
Stark
not just any living stark and when bad
ass little Lyanna Mormont proposed that
John become da cunha to norv she
specifically mentioned that he was the
son of Ned Stark I don't care if he's a
busted that stops good runs through his
veins
so this secret getting out could still
make things pretty awkward for John but
remember John still doesn't know any of
this stuff so I think part of season
seven will show how he comes to learn
this information and there's a few ways
this could happen the obvious way is
bran just makes it south to Winterfell
and tells John himself
obviously brand knows through his howard
joy vision but still that vision only
told brand that Liana was John's mother
it didn't confirm that Rhaegar was the
father or whether they were married when
John was born which would legally make
John a Targaryen and heir to the throne
so I predict that we'll see another
flashback through brands eyes showing us
Liana with Rhaegar maybe that could be
the famous attorney of Harrenhal which
began their whole love affair or maybe a
secret wedding ceremony and in this
flashback we will learn Jon Targaryen
birth name and there are other ways Jon
could find out Sam is currently in the
Citadel library which contains all the
old books and records of Westeros and
it's possible that one of those books
has an old marriage record or a birth
record and we'll see Sam using old books
to debunk the mystery of Jon's lineage
and his actual name the same way Ned
Stark used good old-fashioned research
to debunk the mystery of Joffrey's
lineage there are also a few other
characters who know this secret like
Howland Reed who was with Ned Stark at
the Tower of joy and his daughter Meera
is still with bran and I suppose it's
possible that we may end up meeting
Howland - also I speculated that
Littlefinger might know this truth based
on his suspicious reaction to Sansa in
the Winterfell crib and speaking of
those crypts we brought up a theory in
our episode 9 breakdown last season that
Ned Stark may have kept John's headstone
in the crypts which would reveal his
true identity and we know for the books
that there's a blocked-off
area in the crypts and we still haven't
seen John Barrie Rickon down there so
that could be a way John learns the
secret okay moving on to another
question from Jan on Facebook do you
think there will be a huge fight on the
sea between Daenerys is army and you're
on Greyjoy's army so let's talk about
Daenerys in my other video I predicted
that there would be a massive sea battle
between Daenerys his fleet and you're on
Greyjoy fleet paying off that
foreshadowing that the show gave us back
in episode 5 and I still believe this
because these two clearly seem to be on
a collision course and my previous
assumption was that Daenerys would just
cut right through your on burn King's
Landing to the ground and feed Cersei to
Drogo
but knowing this show I don't think
things will go down that efficiently for
example what happened the last time a
seemingly unsinkable fleet was about to
sack King's Landing oh right
so the lesson here is never
underestimate the Lannisters and I'll
get to Circe in a bit but there's also
nothing that says Daenerys his next move
has to be this big sea battle like her
dragons would definitely hell but she
doesn't really need to be there
considering she can just delegate more
capable naval commanders like you're a
Greyjoy to stand up to their uncle
you're on while Danny takes care of
other important business which leads me
to this tweet from Anthony do you think
Daenerys will make a stop at Dragonstone
so I didn't think about this before but
Daenerys making a pit stop at
Dragonstone makes a lot more sense than
just Leroy Jenkinson into King's Landing
Dragonstone is the ancestral home of the
Targaryen family and Daenerys is
birthplace and Stannis left it pretty
much undefended or at least no defenses
that will hold up against dragons so I
think that there's a very good chance
that in season seven Daenerys will
reclaim her old home of Dragonstone
and set up kind of her like base of
operations there as she makes a case for
herself as a rightful heir to the Iron
Throne now let's move on to another
question from Anders on Facebook will
there be a lion on top of King's Landing
in the intro now that Cersei sits on the
throne great question Anders now let's
talk about Cersei and the implications
of a rule so for this entire series
whenever the opening credits have shown
King's Landing there's been a Baratheon
sigil of the stag on the map and that's
because Robert Baratheon and as far as
the public is concerned Joffrey and
Tommen as well they're all part of the
Baratheon family but Cersei really isn't
she was only a Baratheon through
marriage and through her children and
now Robert and her children are all dead
she's claiming the iron throne for
herself and since Cersei has always had
more pride in her Lannister roots
wearing the Lannister colors of crimson
and gold with Lion embroidery
I predict that she will return to her
Lannister name and will see a lion over
King's Landing in the opening credits
and I know I said before that Circe's
rule over King's Landing will be
short-lived and I still believe that
just because there's only 13 episodes
left and I really don't think the series
will end with Cersei on the Iron Throne
more predictions on that later but I
think season 7 will show us what a
King's Landing ruled under Cersei will
look like even if it's just for a few
episodes like for example Cersei still
has some damage control to do after
nuking the great Sept with wildfire last
season it seemed like religious frenzy
had taken over King's Landing so
seriously it's facing an entire city of
angry poor faithful people who all hate
her guts
and with the remnants of the faith
militant still threatening her but
here's my theory remember the season
finale had that shot that I think really
wanted Cersei to look like the Roman
Emperor Nero who infamously set the city
of Rome on fire and blamed it on the new
radical monotheistic religion that had
taken over the city Christianity and I
think Game of Thrones might borrow from
history again with Cersei blaming this
fire on the show's version of early
Christians followers of the Lord of
Light who by the way are obsessed with
fire and then that would justify a holy
war to break out in King's Landing with
Cersei sweeping out the remaining
religious fanatics and based on the way
she tortured septa unella in the season
finale Cersei seems really eager to do
this meanwhile when it comes to facing
Daenerys forces Cersei still has a few
cards that she can play sure she's made
enemies out of most of the major power
players in Westeros the Starks the
Tyrells and Martel's but Littlefinger
controls the Knights of the Vale which
is currently I think the largest army in
Westeros and his loyalty to Sansa the
Starks seems like something that could
be bought away for the right offer also
as Queen Cersei could easily make a deal
with Joran Greyjoy operating the Iron
Islands autonomy in exchange for their
defense
so I predict that Cersei will play at
least one of these horny ambitious
opportunists who like pushing people to
their deaths to her advantage but let's
move on to our next question from will
on Facebook will Jamie turn on Cersei
this season or next maybe this season
finale so Jamie turning on Cersei seems
inevitable based on that cold glare you
gave her actually got crowned so the
question is how long will it take for
this to happen and what will that
betrayal look like so in the last video
I talked about that Mad Queen theory
which suggests that Cersei has become so
much like the Mad King trying to burn
down the city with wildfire that Jaime
will be forced back into that difficult
choice of killing her to becoming both a
Kingslayer and a queen Slayer that would
affirm that Valon car theory from the
books in which the wood which
prophesized that Cersei would die at the
hands of her bolon car that's a Valyrian
word for a younger brother now I think
that could be possible but I don't see
it happening soon maybe season 7 finale
at the earliest
I just think Cersei and Jaime's
relationship is just too central to the
show and I think we're gonna see these
two until the bitter end also there are
plenty of other ways Cersei could die
like I mentioned Arya and Daenerys
dragons but Cersei has a
their bone car Tirion duh and while it
is possible that Searcy could die at
Tyrians hands I'm more interested in the
questions of how much of a brother
Tyrion actually is to Cersei so we
mentioned this in our breakdowns last
season but one of the more popular fan
theories out there is that Tyrians
father is not Tywin
but the Mad King Aerys Targaryen who
many believed raped Joanna Lannister she
was the wife of Tywin who was hand to
the king at the time now Tywin obviously
wasn't the warmest father figure to
Tyrion and I guess you could take that
literally and this theory would help
further explain Tywin's extreme hatred
of Tyrion also when Tyrion unshackled
Daenerys is dragons
they seem strangely warm to him as if he
might have Targaryen blood and in the
books Daenerys has visions of the house
of the undying featured a passage saying
that the dragon had three heads which
many interpret to mean Daenerys John and
Tyrion but to be honest I think this
theory is still very much a stretch to
me it kind of sounds like a less
interesting version of the Jon Targaryen
theory but if this show does go in this
direction I still don't think that we'll
see it in season 7 right after the
reveal about Jon because it would just
be too sudden like we can handle
back-to-back bloody weddings but
seriously is everyone on the show
Targaryen now come on okay let's move on
to another character you guys are asking
about bran so I already mentioned how I
think bran will travel south of the wall
to Winterfell and I had a few more
thoughts on that but quickly I want to
talk about brands ability to affect the
past which was revealed in the amazing
hold the door episode last season now
remember right after that we saw bran
downloading visions of the past and
future from the previous three-eyed
Raven including shots of the Mad King as
he screamed to burn them all and one
theory is that this nonsensical command
from the Mad King will be revealed as
another Hodor moment with bran under
attack from a bunch of whites screaming
burn them all and then accidentally
connecting to the mind of the Mad King
in the past basically turning the Mad
King mad by filling his head with these
crazy voices another time travel related
theory is that bran is the same brand
the Builder who was the ancient founder
of the House Stark and the one who
oversaw the construction of the wall
using magic from the children of the
forest to keep out the White Walkers now
the books go into the history of bran
the Builder a lot more describing him as
a young boy making people think that
this could have been
brand that we know from the show
traveling back thousands of years to
protect Westeros from this greater
threat but the show hasn't really gotten
in this history as much as the books
have and I'll admit that these series
are pretty cool and I could talk about
various possibilities to try and travel
for like hours but I feel like the show
is not going in this direction the idea
of time travel is one of those
storytelling devices where unless you're
going to go deep into it and make the
entire story about time like back to the
future or Donnie Darko or looper it's
really hard to balance the storytelling
where time travel can make anything
possible
it's especially tricky for serialized
stories like Game of Thrones that are
really about other things like when time
travel came up in the later seasons of
lost I'm not supposed to be here or in
the Harry Potter series and I just don't
think a show about trippy time travel is
really what george RR martin had in mind
when he wrote the Song of Ice and Fire
series I do think that the show will
continue to use brand's ability to see
through time as advice but when it comes
to the ability to change events in the
past I think that the writers feel that
it's probably safer to keep that
confined to this one interesting
emotional moment with Hodor as opposed
to opening the can of worms and letting
it change everything in the show but
speaking of the wall we got this
question from Rowena 28 on Instagram
will bran break the walls magic and
allow the White Walkers to get through
yeah this is something that I brought up
in the last video and in that hold the
door episode the ninth Cain gave brand
mark that allowed him to bypass magical
barriers that normally kept the White
Walkers out so the thought is that brand
crossing south of the wall will allow
the White Walkers to follow him and that
that wall will come down which would be
an epic image to end the season on and
even though I still think that the
season after season eight will be more
focused on the war against the White
Walkers
I do think season 7 will show us a lot
more about them because remember most
people in Westeros still don't believe
the White Walkers even exist they look
at them as like the boogeyman killed a
white Walker good news I think so I
predict that at least part of season 7
will deal with the people of Westeros
coming to terms with the White Walkers
and their reanimated White's as a real
threat and I think that might involve us
seen a lot more of them learning about
their history their culture maybe some
of their tools and the beasts that they
use and I think a lot of that
information will be explained to us by
this guy
justin tweeted us asking about samwell's
impact on the endgame so in the last
video I predicted that Sam being in the
center of all knowledge of Westeros the
Citadel library in Old Town will
position him for a few key functions
proving John's Targaryen lineage teaming
up with Jorah to discover a cure for
greyscale and of course researching the
White Walkers and developing a strategy
to defeat them build in on his
experience of killing a white Walker
with dragonglass
or maybe examining his father's Valyrian
steel sword hearts pain to learn the
properties of that forgotten art so that
he can forge these weapons on a mass
scale but we also got this question from
Ammar who do you think the new guy who
got casted will be playing so I assume
you're referring to Jim Broadbent who's
a well-known British character actor who
you might know as Professor Slughorn
from the Harry Potter movies so my
prediction is that he's going to be
playing an old kooky maester in the
Citadel who teaches Sam about this form
of magic that his colleagues are
skeptical about kind of like how
Slughorn explained to a young bull
d'amore what Horcruxes were Sam could be
like maester I read something rather odd
about a bit of RAM magic and in the
maesters like looking to kill what walk
was all you and then he just like opens
his robe showing dozens of Valyrian
steel and dragonglass daggers I got it
all figured out anyway speaking of
forging blades let's move on to another
character a lot of people are asking
about Gendry now we were all pretty
certain that Gendry would just be this
loose thread to the show never bothered
to tie up leaving him like rowing a boat
across the sea for years and years and
years but rumor has it that Gendry might
return this season and i think with that
we should interpret the return of Benjen
stark as confirmation that this series
does not want to leave any loose threads
dangling and there's a few ways that
Gendry could come back into the story
like he could be the Smith whom Sam
relies on to forge Valyrian steel for
the whole realm or he could rejoin Arya
as she makes her way through the
Riverlands or team up with the
Brotherhood without banners or maybe
we'll just see him like brewing in the
middle of the naval battle with Joran
Greyjoy just like let me pass please
don't kill me
either way I'm excited to see this guy
come back okay one last character that
you guys asked about was Littlefinger so
I've spoken before about how
Littlefinger might try to manipulate
Sansa against John using the secret of
his fur garyun lineage and how
Littlefinger might betray the Starks and
flip the Knights of the Vale to support
Cersei but one theory that I haven't
talked about is how far back little
fingers manipulations go pacifically
some people think that Littlefinger has
been
pulling the strings on events since the
very beginning and that he was the one
who started the lie that Rhaegar
kidnapped and raped Liana as opposed to
the two of them just consensually
running off together all so that he
could start a war and then upset the
status quo so that he could align with
the winning side and move up in the
world remember this is all
Littlefinger's mo he had that great
moment with various chaos a gating pit
waiting to swallow us all chaos isn't a
pit chaos is a ladder and if bran has a
flashback to the turning of Harrenhal
this line could be something that we see
on the show in season seven but this
brings me to the main question people
are asking about which goes to the theme
at the heart of the show when you play
the game of Thrones you win will you die
who will die and who gets the throne so
I've already discussed whether or not
characters like Arya and Cersei might
die in season seven I also feel like
there's a lot of minor characters that
fans have just been waiting to see get
killed off like sand snakes or the
Greyjoy's but when we're coming to the
end of the series we have to look at
whose deaths will have the most meaning
and the most impact of the story and by
the way that doesn't always mean human
characters they're also the direwolves
ghosts and Ameria and Daenerys is
dragons like all of these creatures are
at risk but when I rank which characters
I think are most likely to die
definitely have to consider those loyal
warriors that have somehow survived up
into this point like Brienne and bran
and grey worm I also think the Hound
Sandor Clegane may be in the process of
a Redemption arc that might see him
sacrificing himself for some greater
good I also worry that Littlefinger may
not make it out of this season alive
like I feel like his manipulations will
either catch up to him with Sansa and
Cersei saying enough is enough
or in a less likely scenario he'll
somehow fool them all and make it all
the way to the top so let's close out by
talking about who will end up on the
iron throne Littlefinger has arguably
done the most to play the political game
and giving him the throne seems like
something george RR martin would do to
underline game of thrones general
cynical attitude towards politics and
then of course Jon and Daenerys are in
competition to be the most rightful
heirs John is all ready to commune to
norv and if Rhaegar was legally married
to Liana when he was born that makes
John's claim to the Iron Throne even
more legitimate than Danny's and of all
the characters John is the most noble
and commendable honestly probably the
holiday that best shows that you deserve
the Iron Throne is not wanting it and
then Daenerys obviously has the largest
forces at her command along with dragons
which honestly seem to give her some
divine providence and she has experience
she's proven to be pretty wise and I
think that her struggle to rule over
marine has given her some legit wisdom
and experience in both Daenerys in
John's cases their journeys from humble
beginnings out to the far reaches of the
world to death and resurrection and back
home both pretty much complete that
archetypal hero's journey and either of
them really fit the description of the
prince that was promised so we'll just
have to see whose story this is is it
John's or is it Daenerys is or is it
both in some way now again I don't think
the series is going to end with Cersei
on the throne but I do think that
there's a chance that we could see
Tyrion on the chair either the show
could reveal his Targaryen lineage which
could give him a legal right to the
throne or Daenerys could make him Lord
Protector to rule the realm while she
deals with the White Walkers in effect
giving him control over the Iron Throne
but really I think one of the outcomes
that I'm more interested in was actually
brought up recently by Finn Jones who
played the late Loras Tyrell throw it
would be sold in the process but
physically I do not repeat so you don't
think there's gonna be someone at the
end of the season sitting on the Iron
Throne
now Ben Jones isn't attached to the show
anymore and his guesses are really as
good as ours
but honestly this makes a lot of sense
perhaps the best way to end this series
isn't just to turn the wheel and put
some other deserving or intentionally
undeserving character in power but to do
what Daenerys promised I'm not going to
stop the wheel I'm going to break the
wheel and leave Westeros with some new
better form of government and I would
say that better form of government is
democracy but lately that system has
been [ __ ] too so we'll see okay let me
know what you think in the comments and
thank you to everyone who sent us
questions and keep an eye out for future
Game of Thrones videos on this channel
hopefully a season 7 trailer will be
coming out soon and we'll be back with
more predictions and theories now if you
like this video please hit like and
subscribe the new rock stars and share
this video with all your friends and if
you really like us and you want to see
us do more Q&A videos like this you can
help us by contributing to patreon a
huge thanks to all of our current donors
especially Kenny Smith you are my hero
Kenny thank you so much and for the rest
of you if you're not currently a donor
we would love your support you can hit
me up on twitter at EA boss with any
thoughts or theories on Game of Thrones
or you can
new rockstars on Twitter at new rock
stars alright thanks for watching bye
you